welcome to Market takes welcome in thank
you so much for being with us no you
could have been anywhere in the world
right now but you're here with me and I
appreciate that listen we are unpacking
today's non-farm payroll support aka the
jobs report
um today was a very interesting report
that we got and I think we've gotten a
very interesting Market reaction to the
report and I think to a lot of other
things going on out there there's a lot
of noise a lot of things you know
contrasting indicators things that don't
really match up we are here to break it
down and explain what matters separate
that signal from that noise and talk
about what's really going on in the
market in the economy and what means
what it means when we read through the
numbers in this jobs report I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal thank you all so much again for
being with us we're going to talk about
what this report said what today's jobs
report said how it compared to
expectations and what we should take
away from that we're going to talk about
the trajectory the big term trajectory
because it's not really about one number
it's about how that number fits in with
other numbers within the economy and
other previous numbers we're going to
talk about all that we're of course
going to talk about the market reaction
analyze what that means we're going to
explain the current markets the current
market focus on jobs maybe the lack of
focus on this particular report and then
of course we're going to talk about what
comes next because there's some very
interesting and very important reports
coming out next week in terms of what's
going to happen next for the economy for
the the market the stock market all that
good stuff coming up so without further
Ado let's talk about today the non-farm
payrolls report from April April's job
support showed 253 000 jobs added last
month that was well above the
expectations which were for 180 000 jobs
added so this was a surprising increase
in terms of the number of jobs added now
the context here is that the April
surprise contrasted with revisions lower
for both February and March February and
March will revised lower by 149 000 and
jobs so we beat the expectation by about
70 000 jobs but then the previous two
months were revised lower by a hundred
fifty thousand jobs almost now that is a
big deal because it slows the overall
pace of jobs added for the US economy
over the last three months and it
changes the picture completely in terms
of what we're looking at on the jobs
front
the biggest piece of this report though
I think when you read through the
numbers and you really dig into the
report the biggest number is the average
hourly earnings number now that
increased to 4.4 percent year over year
and 0.5 percent month over month those
numbers by themselves don't mean
anything but coming into this month we
had 4.2 percent consistent average
year-over-year hourly earnings now we've
seen an increase average hourly earnings
have increased and well well above
expectations expectations was for them
to stay at point three percent month
over month and four point two percent
year over year we're above that and so
average hourly earnings are increasing
meaning workers are getting more money
higher pay being able to demand bigger
raises than they had been back in March
and that's a big deal because wages we
know lead to inflation and the Federal
Reserve has been laser focused locked in
on these earnings numbers they say wages
are too high employees have too much are
able to demand too much have too much
leverage on their side because there are
lots more job openings and there are
unemployed people well this showing that
those pressures have not abated even
though some things have happened so
you're going to want to keep your eye on
what happens with inflation we've got a
big report coming out next week I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
but wages have been lower than overall
inflation have been pulling that number
down even after this report wages at 4.4
percent overall an overall inflation was
at five percent so we are still seeing
wages below but now what you're seeing
is overall inflation is coming down
while wages which had been kind of
coming down and then holding well now
they're picking back up that makes a big
difference especially because you're
seeing the pace of overall jobs growth
slowdown it's also important to note
another big developing story my man John
Butters over at factset he points out
that corporate earnings is a net profits
those are starting to pick back up we
saw corporate net earnings or I'm sorry
excuse me net profit margins for big
corporations S P 500 companies those are
picking back up again Rising after 6 six
straight quarters of declining corporate
profits as a net profit margin says in
just how much money corporations are
able to make from every dollar of their
sales that's increasing again and rising
and that's the biggest contributor to
inflation so we're seeing all these
developments that suggest that inflation
while it had been coming down could be
picking back up now let's talk about
jobs a little bit I want to get into the
trajectory that we talked about of that
jobs growth put something up here on
your screen to just show you what we're
looking at overall in terms of the jobs
growth now on the left side of your
screen you see from 2013 to 2020
jobs really got above that 250 000 per
month added number right you see very
rarely do they get above that line that
250k line now when you go to 2021 and
Beyond up through today well they're
pretty regularly above that 250k line
and even sometimes peaking above that
750k line but you see the trajectory
over the last few months with a couple
outliers in there you see consistently
moving down and moving lower and now
we've seen with March and with February
and March revised lower you're seeing
now a consistent theme of job growth
lower than it had been moving back
toward that Trend that we had seen over
10 years before the pandemic and moving
back towards that lower growth so that
just illustrating the overall trajectory
of jobs growth and the way that we've
seen that move and it's moving toward a
lower area of lower and decreased job
growth that's not a good thing that had
been a good thing because job growth
more hiring means higher wages means
more inflation the Fed has been working
to keep that down however we could be
getting to a point where we're seeing
higher wages wages stay higher and pick
back up while jobs growth the number of
jobs added declines that points to
stagflation potentially and that is
potentially the worst possible outcome
because it's where you have inflation
high but the economy weak and those are
just two things you don't want to see
coming together let's look at the
numbers a little bit now the March
number was revised lower to 165 000 jobs
added from 236 000. so that's down about
60 70 000. in February it was revised
down to 248 000 from 326 000. all that's
telling you is that we're seeing numbers
revised down lower and you could expect
to see this April number revised lower
as well again we are still well above
where we were the previous 10 years but
moving in a worrisome Direction and in
fact the three-month Trend which had
been at 345 000 jobs added over the as
an average over the last three months
well now that's 222 jobs at it that is a
significant difference between 345 000
jobs added 222 000 jobs added as an
average over the past three months
that's a big step down
and that's meaningful over the last six
months we're at 290 000 jobs so over the
six month period 290 000 over the three
month period two hundred twenty two
thousand you're just seeing this trend
moving lower and slower and this is
something I don't know the market is
really looking at right now in terms of
the trend and the trajectory now I want
to explain really quickly how revisions
work now a lot of folks don't understand
what happens is the Bureau of Labor
Statistics they have a household survey
and an employer survey and they send
surveys out to companies they say how
many people do you have working for you
they call people and they say hey do you
have a job does everyone your family
have a job when they put the report out
they do this over a couple weeks during
the middle of the month not everybody
responds as those responses come in
maybe later in the month maybe the next
month they revise those previous months
slower so what they've gotten is they've
gotten new numbers for February and
March and those numbers show there was
actually less hiring done because this
is all based on averages this is based
on assumptions the Bureau of Labor
system 6 doesn't go to every single
company in the United States and say how
many people you got working for you they
don't call up every household they call
up a sample and they come up with an
average well those averages have changed
based on the number of new survey
responses that have come in and that's
pointing to a more worrisome Trend a
lower slower trend of job growth than
what we had seen and what we thought we
had seen earlier this year so a very
clear trend of slowing jobs growth and
that's worrisome for the overall economy
let's take a look at the market and talk
about how the market reacted to it I'm
going to put this here up on your screen
and what you're seeing right now is live
Futures now I wanted to talk first about
crude oil because oil has really taken
off exploding you see oil on Brent Brent
and WTI both have about four a little
over four percent gold down that's
usually a sign of you know worries
coming out of the market because people
pile into gold and buy gold when they're
worried about things silver another one
of those things you're also seeing
copper way up copper up almost one
percent right now so overall a bullish
day on the market when we turn to the
stock market as well we are seeing a dow
up about one and a half percent the
NASDAQ up one and a half percent the S P
500 also up almost one and a half
percent I want to give you a little bit
more idea of what we're looking at
bigger picture and you see this big jump
before the market opened today you see
the S P 500 just really taken off now
some places where you might be seeing a
little bit of the worry right a bit of
the worry about this report the currency
market look at the US dollar Index now
we know when things get rough people
pile into the safety of the US dollar
that's what's been happening lately is
we've seen the dollar move higher this
was right around 8 o'clock AM or 8 30
when that jobs report number came out
you see a big jump in the US dollar
Index we're coming off that a little bit
but you just see that's one place where
you might be seeing some of the worry
about this report coming into play so
that just illustrating how the market is
responding right now not a lot of
worries stock market I think is being
moved on other factors we're seeing a
big bounce back in some of those Bank
shares some those Regional Bank stocks
that got sold and hit really hard over
the past few days Pac West is about 40
percent also Apple which is a huge part
of the overall S P 500 a big part of the
NASDAQ has a big day it's up about five
percent it's best day so far in about
four or five months uh happening right
now in terms of Apple stock and again
Apple a big part of the overall S P 500
and the NASDAQ so that I think is why
we're seeing those movements in the
stock market but right now we are seeing
a risk on day and I think the market not
really reacting to some of these worries
that are present and maybe a little bit
buried in that jobs report just saying
that overall 253k number and people
saying okay well let's focus on other
things and take a look at that
listen let's take a step back and talk
about why the market should be focused
and why this jobs report matters the FED
wants to slow the pace of job growth it
wants to slow down the pace of the
overall economy so that people stop
spinning they stop going out and buying
things they say you know what prices are
too high I need to stay here at home not
take out a home equity loan not borrow
money not start a business not take on
some more debt to to increase the size
of my business because it's just too
expensive and that's the goal they want
to slow inflation down with their rate
hikes by making rates higher that is not
good for the stock market and so overall
when you look at the jobs Market the FED
wants it to slow down they want people
to lose their jobs because that's the
only way for inflation to come back down
meaningfully Fed chair Jerome Powell
yesterday at his press conference that's
something that I thought was very
interesting especially for someone who's
been in these Economist circles who's
surrounded by economists even though he
may not be a trained Economist himself
he said I continue to think it's
possible that this time is really
different and I thought that was
interesting because we know as investors
as economists as folks who watch the
market the most worrisome words in all
of Finance are it's different this time
and Fed chair Jerome Powell coming out
and saying yeah I think it may be
different this time what he meant is
that maybe there doesn't have to be a
painful long recession because of the
fed's raid hiking cycle it may be
different in a way other than what he
thinks and what this jobs report today
is suggesting is that it could be
different in that jobs start to decline
the economy goes down and and really
hits a worrisome place but inflation may
stay high the FED may have to keep
raising rates to get inflation back down
while the economy starts to do worse and
have worse outcomes for folks and that
could be the way that it's different
this time again this is just one report
at one reported Trend does not make but
there are some worrisome Trends in this
report also when we're looking at the
overall labor market we've seen the
jolts report the last couple reports of
shown a significant decrease in job
openings and increase in layoffs overall
businesses are cutting workers and
they're not announcing as many job
openings this has been a consistent
Trend we've seen in the jolts report the
job opening and labor turnover survey we
have seen also the Challenger job Cuts
report that came out we've seen it pick
up a pronounced increase in job Cuts as
in layoffs as in folks getting fired we
have seen that from both of those
reports again not at worrisome
historical levels but we have seen a
pickup from the very low levels that we
had seen previously and we are starting
to enter a potential environment of
higher stress and works numbers
especially in the manufacturing
construction sectors things like that
fed manufacturing surveys from across
the country Kansas City fed San
Francisco fed New York fed they've all
showed some of the worst numbers over
the last three months that we've seen
since 2020 since mid-2020 and those were
some of the worst numbers that we'd seen
in history and we are seeing
consistently those reports along with
pmi's purchasing manage index surveys of
hiring managers and folks who run
businesses and makes big business
decisions saying things are getting
worse and they're the worst they've been
since mid-2020. so the manufacturing
sector which is a small part of the US
economy but an important part an
important part of the economy has been
showing a lot of stress and we are
starting to see some of those numbers
another place where we are seeing some
stress is in the banks I want to put
something up here on your screen to just
show you an illustration of that stress
that we are seeing in the banking sector
this is the senior loan officer opinion
survey basically how many banks are
raising tightening lending standards
what that means simply is banks are
making it harder to lend they are
raising the necessary criteria whereas
let's say the last survey was done in
January so let's say in December they
were saying okay you need a 700 credit
score to borrow money now they're saying
you need 750. whereas previously in
surveys they'd say okay well you need a
hundred thousand dollars in collateral
now they're saying two hundred thousand
dollars in collateral and you got to
have this and you got to have that that
you didn't have before because banks are
getting worried this survey right here
you see at the edge of your screen on
the right it's already up at levels that
are associated with recessions every one
of those dark patches or those gray
patches you see on your screen or where
we've had a recession and every time
tightening of lending standards gets a
level that it's at right now and again
this is before everything happened with
Silicon Valley Bank with First Republic
Bank this is before we are already at
levels that are associated with and have
been and have been precursors to
recession we are already there and we
get the latest update to this survey on
May 8th next week
that's going to be highly watched most
people don't really pay that much
attention to the senior loan officer
survey I think they will be this month
and that could be a market moving report
so you're going to want to watch out for
that but again we are already as you can
see here on this chart at recession
levels in terms of banks tightening
lending standards and that will likely
increase when we get the latest numbers
on May 8th so this chart is just an
illustration of the overall sentiment in
terms of banks right now that we're
seeing in the economy another
potentially bad sign for the future and
for what could be coming on the economy
um listen we are going to wrap this up
for Market takes I thank everybody for
being with us this was a very
interesting and a very complex report
um and I think there's going to be a lot
more to come from it I think we're going
to be talking about this report over the
next couple weeks if not throughout the
month because this points to a lot of
things that could not be moving or that
could be moving not in the way that the
Federal Reserve wants and as we know
central banks and the Federal Reserve
are everything when it comes to
investing and when it comes to the
economy so you're going to want to watch
out for that what do we got next week on
Monday we will be right here with you on
Market takes telling you what to look
out for the upcoming week next week I
think is going to be a big week for the
market so you'll want to tune in Monday
morning 10 a.m for Market takes and then
on Wednesday we get the CPI inflation
report the consumer price index report
that's coming out Wednesday and we'll be
with you again 10 a.m Wednesday here on
Market takes I hope you'll be with us
for that I am Dion rabone reporter for
the Wall Street Journal that's going to
do it for Market takes I hope you'll be
back with us next time